the stars of famous ad campaigns don't
always go on to have successful Showbiz
careers but when they do they prefer to
become character actors podcasters
reality stars and even turncoats
in Slim Jim's bizarre commercials from
the 90s a single bite of the spicy meat
stick sends a wiry monster banging
around stomach walls Dimitri garitzas
was the actor behind that Madness and
he's since built up a respectable career
of character acting and voiceover work
he's narrated more than 100
documentaries about things like
earthquakes and volcanoes and he's
appeared in commercials for everything
from orange juice to beer you may have
also spotted garitza's in the 2015 movie
Everest and the Black Mirror episode
nosedive his other credits include small
parts in such films as Saving Private
Ryan and X-Men first Class and he's
shown up on stage in Productions of
plays like boy gets girl and ear for eye
hate me
Pete Gardner is known far and wide for
his impressively bushy mustache as he
and his facial hair have been a
memorable part of various commercials he
played a goofy dad in a postal service
ad a patient dad listening to his kids
Wii U sales pitch for Nintendo a
truck-loving Salesman for Chevy James
Harden's beard Guru for NBA 2K15 and a
guy in a locker room who can make his
armpit talk for Juicy Fruit gum Gardner
also has a resume full of interesting
roles on movies and TV that goes back
decades he's probably best known as the
supportive and emotionally open lawyer
Daryl white feather on Crazy
Ex-Girlfriend
John mashita Jr became a minor celebrity
in the 80s thanks to a rather singular
talent that is his ability to talk
really really fast Once Upon a Time he
could get through 586 words a minute
this record has since been beaten but it
remains mind-blowing he made the rounds
of talk and variety shows to demonstrate
his talents and he also showed up in
lots and lots of ads somebody's instant
rice has been suggesting it's just as
fast and reliable as men advice don't
you believe it most famously mashita
played a harried executive who needs his
documents in a FedEx commercial he was
also a motor-mouthed pitchman from Micro
Machines a line of tiny toy cars he's
pulled back from public life a bit but
in 2011 he was back in the advertising
Groove as a pitch man for JetBlue then
in 2014 he showed up on The Tonight Show
to speedily summarize that Year's
Academy Award nominees for Best Picture
Ben Curtis had some good news for TV
viewers in the early 2000s dude you're
getting Adele in an endless string of
commercials for the then dominant PC
manufacturer Curtis played a fratty guy
sporting spiky blonde hair and hemp
necklaces who was always happy to extol
the virtues of Dell computers with his
half-closed eyes and laid-back mood he
also seemed a little bit stoned indeed
when it was discovered that he actually
did smoke marijuana at a time when it
was illegal pretty much everywhere in
the U.S it's spelled the end of his Dell
Hitchman days Curtis was reportedly
arrested on a drug possession charge
after a police officer in New York
spotted him buying a small amount of pot
in 2003 he then couldn't find any acting
work for a while so he tried his hand at
bartending and staged an
autobiographical theater piece about his
experience as the Dell dude he also
co-founded a yoga Centric gym called
solfeit NY and now works as a life coach
Hallie Eisenberg parlayed a career as a
child actor in commercials into some big
movies and major TV shows she first hit
screens as the button cute curly-haired
star of a series of late 90s Pepsi ads
with the voices of Aretha Franklin and
Joe Pesci amusingly dubbed in
Eisenberg then moved on to the likes of
Bicentennial Man a TV movie version of
The Miracle Worker and the owner of a
talking parrot voiced by Jay Moore in
the family movie Paulie after a few more
movies and some theatrical performances
Eisenberg whose older brother is Jesse
Eisenberg quit acting altogether in 2010
reportedly to focus on College her last
on-screen credited role was an
appearance at the 2013 Tony Awards
thanks to the enduring popularity of the
Smash Hit musical Hamilton a certain
iconic 90s ad has enjoyed a bit of a
Revival in the first got milk commercial
which aired in 1993 an Aaron Burr expert
tries to answer a radio trivia question
but he can only Mumble because he
doesn't have any milk to wash his peanut
butter sandwich down
I'm sorry
this unlucky historian was played by
Sean Whalen a hard-working performer
with more than 140 acting credits to his
name Weyland is probably best known
among comedy fans for his role as lion a
member of the mcpoyle family on its
Always Sunny in Philadelphia he was also
well regarded for his recurring part of
creepy employee Sal on the NBC sitcom
Superstore
Budweiser's what's up campaign was
simple silly and endearing the premise
was that a bunch of guys call each other
on the phone just to ask what's up the
question gets louder and more incoherent
with each utterance these ads were based
on true a short film directed by Charles
Stone III Stone also appears in the film
and the ad surrounded by some of his
real-life friends true hit the film
festival circuit and was discovered by
Ad Agency ddb which led to what's up
debuting during Monday Night Football in
December 1999. true true Stone had
already directed some classic hip-hop
videos like Public Enemies 9-1-1 is a
joke and The Roots what they do but the
Budweiser spot helped push him into
feature filmmaking among his directorial
credits are the 2002 musical Drumline
the 2004 baseball movie Mr 3000 and the
2018 basketball comedy Uncle Drew which
in an appropriate twist was based on a
commercial for Pepsi
Wendy Kaufman stumbled into her
star-making gig as snapple's
spokesperson completely by accident in
1990 she was working in the company's
billing department and she took it upon
herself to answer letters from customers
because nobody else in the office would
an ad exec heard about that and then
created a campaign built around Kaufman
answering Snapple consumers questions
those spots then helped turn Snapple
into a major national beverage brand
after 17 years with the iced tea and
lemonade giant Kaufman left Snapple in
2008 in the wake of a corporate takeover
by Quaker Oats and a failure to
negotiate a mutually agreeable contract
in 2005 she appeared on VH1's weight
loss reality show celebrity Fit club and
then in 2015 she had a small part in the
Indie comedy College debts
Jerry Lambert has starred in many major
ad campaigns this success is due in
large part to his Everyman face that
surely reminds many viewers of their dad
or boss he's worked for the likes of
Geico Wendy's Burger King and most
notably Sony in an ad for PlayStation he
played Kevin Butler the company's
comically smarmy and fictional vice
president Lambert lost that gig in 2012
after he appeared in an ad for
Bridgestone which promised customers who
buy new tires a free Wii made by
Nintendo one of Sony's biggest Rivals
Sony sued Lambert and the case was
ultimately settled when he agreed not to
appear in any video game ads for two
years fortunately roles on TV shows
started to roll in for Lambert since his
fake corporate days came to an end he's
popped up on the likes of key and peel
Brooklyn Nine-Nine an American housewife
where he had a regular gig as bumbling
principal ablin
John Hodgman had just landed a gig as a
contributor on The Daily Show with Jon
Stewart when apples get a Mac campaign
kicked off he played PC the bumbling
ancient technology foil to Justin Long's
Mac the youthful and cool alternative
hello I'm a Mac and I'm a PC we've got a
little Network going here the campaign
spawned 66 ads and made Hodgman a
recognizable face to millions of TV
viewers he's since gone on to perform
stand-up hosts the mock trial podcast
Judge John Hodgman and published several
books Hodgman also has a steady acting
career in which he's usually cast as a
stodgy nerd he's shown up on the likes
of the tick and Parks and Recreation and
he also co-created and stars on the
animated FX comedy detective series
dicktown
a computer-generated TV host from the
future Max Headroom was created for a
1985 British dystopian sci-fi movie
called Max Headroom 20 minutes into the
future he proved so popular that he got
his own music video show and then his
own TV series that aired on ABC for two
seasons Coca-Cola also landed the rights
to use him in commercials for new Coke
the company's short-lived misguided
attempt in 1985 to reformulate its
Flagship product and let's try Coco Coke
again shall we Max wasn't actually
computer generated instead he was actor
Matt frewer under multiple layers of
makeup and Prosthetics that were meant
to make him look digitally created when
the character's popularity faded threw a
returned to his career as a quirky
character actor he's appeared in movies
and shows like Honey I Shrunk the Kids
Orphan Black and HBO's Perry Mason
Revival
in a series of early 2000s commercials
Orbit gum is touted for its ability to
make one's mouth feel clean under any
circumstances the spots prove this by
having an upstanding British woman
exposed hapless individuals to a series
of dirty ordeals hazards like muddy dogs
Road dust and Tennis Court dirt cover
them from head to toe but orbit reliably
keeps their teeth a pristine white
fabulous Vanessa Branch played this
cheeky pitch woman from 2002 to 2005.
she's a very busy working actor Beyond
commercials as well you might remember
her as Giselle a flax and haired Beauty
from the pirate island of Tortuga and
the Pirates of the Caribbean movies in
2013 she served as a judge on the VH1
reality show model employee her most
recent credit is from a 2017 short film
called Silent Kingdom
when Dave Thomas opened the first
Wendy's old-fashioned hamburgers in
Columbus Ohio in 1969 he named the
business after his daughter Melinda her
brothers and sisters couldn't pronounce
that name so they called her Wendy
instead the real Wendy has occasionally
appeared in the chains commercials but
in 2012 the company wanted to promote
itself with a living mascot so they
hired an actor to play a fictionalized
version of Wendy Alabama born Morgan
Smith who dyed her naturally dark blonde
hair for the role the campaign lasted
about two years for Smith after all that
exposure she landed a part on a
never-aired reboot of the sitcom coach
and she also had a recurring gig as the
President's chief of staff on HBO's Veep
and then in 2023 she showed up on an
episode of How I met her father
to demonstrate that it offers
round-the-clock customer service
assistance State Farm ran an ad in the
2010s featuring a Suburban man speaking
discreetly to an unseen caller the man's
wife discovers him and assumes that his
mistress is on the other end so she asks
what she's wearing it's then revealed
that her husband has actually been
speaking to a State Farm Insurance agent
uh
khakis the employee in this commercial
was actually a real State Farm employee
by the name of Jake Stone the ad was so
successful that the insurance company
decided to base an entire campaign
around the character but they made one
major change as they swapped out the
real Jake stone for one played by an
actor named Kevin miles meanwhile the
real Jake Stone retired from acting he
reportedly left his insurance gig and
took a job as a seasonal employee for
the city of Normal Illinois while also
holding down a bartending position
there are a lot of cleaning products out
there but the makers of Pine Sol set
theirs apart by touting how they smell
like evergreen trees a long-running ad
campaign starring an outspoken fan took
them to especially lofty Heights this
dynamite spokeswoman is known as the
Pine-Sol lady and she's been the center
of the household cleaners marketing
campaign since 1993. stand-up comedian
and actor Diane Amos got the gig early
in her career which she's gone on to
balance with work in a wide variety of
movies and TV shows including Blue
Jasmine Sweet November and blunt talk
according to amos's Twitter she also
makes a lot of public appearances and
works as an inspirational speaker
in 2013 a German travel pricing
aggregator called Trivago launched an
English language ad campaign in which a
middle-aged guy walks around a blank set
promising low prices on hotels the
Trivago guy as he became known turned
into a bit of a viral phenomenon pundits
pointed out how unique his wrinkled
clothes and pronounced stubble are among
pitch men and internet commenters
debated whether the results were
off-putting or attractive The Man Behind
this brief phenomenon was Houston native
Tim Williams his acting career began in
the 90s but his breakthrough role was
definitely the Trivago guy prior to
those commercials he landed guest Parts
on shows like The Sopranos before then
finding work in German Productions his
last role to date is Commander Jones in
the post-world War II miniseries are
wonderful years in April 2019 Williams
got into a bit of legal trouble for
drunk driving when he was discovered
asleep at the wheel in the middle of
traffic the Char charges were later
dropped
in an omnipresent ad campaign from the
2000s Verizon Wireless told customers
that they took the coverage and Clarity
of calls on its Network seriously these
commercials depict test man may be
spectacled Verizon employee who travels
around all kinds of terrain to prove the
strength of Verizon's connections can
you hear me now
good but can you hear me now ads aired
from 2002 to 2011 and the test man was
brought to life by actor Paul marcarelli
after Verizon cut him loose the
theater-oriented performer moved into
film he wrote a couple of small movies
called the green and clutter and he
acted in some low budget projects one of
marcarelli's splashiest roles since
leaving Verizon is actually connected to
the performance that made him famous as
he's played himself in a series of ads
for competitor Sprint that referenced
his history with Verizon
can you hear that in 2010 T-Mobile
debuted a series of ads that attempted
to put a human face and personality on
the invisible product of cell phone
service this campaign centers around the
T-Mobile girl a 20-something woman
wearing dresses in the company's
signature magenta color played by Carly
folks she politely extols the benefits
of T-Mobile's calling and data plans the
company went on to reboot the campaign
reimagining their pitch person as a
leather-clad motorcycle riding Action
Hero the ads ended production in 2013
leaving folks free to do other things
having worked as a model before she
became the T-Mobile girl she then moved
into acting appearing in a series of
short films and a music video by the
band collapsing scenery more recently
she's largely moved from working in
front of the camera to behind it
according to her Instagram she now
operates as a photographer and director
and still dabbles in modeling
Sonic is an old-fashioned Drive-In
burger joint with locations around the
United States beginning in the early
2000s it advertised its Wares with a
campaign called two guys the commercials
play like 30 second comedy sketches in
which the titular 2 guys sit outside of
Sonic and enjoy their fast food one of
them is kind of dumb while the other is
humorously exasperated by his dim dining
buddy the continuing Saga of these
friends drove dozens of Sonic ads until
2010 when the company decided to go in
another Direction undeterred the actors
who appeared in the mostly improvised
ads produce their own self-made versions
which eventually led to a renewal of
their gig with Sonic the campaign
ultimately ended for good in 2020. the
two guys behind two guys are TJ
jagadowski as the dumb guy and Peter
Gross as the voice of reason jagadowski
has recently popped up on episodes of
NBC's Chicago Fire and Netflix is easy
while gross has written for Late Night
with Seth Meyer years and he acted in
the 2022 satirical horror flick the menu
doseki's most interesting man in the
world campaign invited consumers to be
more like its fabled subject a deep
voice narrator admiringly in tones this
guy's accomplishments which include the
fact that his shirts don't wrinkle he
bowls overhand he tips 100 and he's won
a Lifetime Achievement Award twice each
ad eventually cuts to a bearded man
who's surrounded by women as he hoists a
bottle of Dos Equis stay thirsty my
friends Jonathan Goldsmith portrayed the
most interesting man in the world
capping a career as a character actor
that began in the early 60s during the
80s he guest starred on seemingly every
major TV drama of the decade including
Knight Rider The A-Team and Dallas
following his work is the most
interesting man in the world Goldsmith
popped up at the end of 2018's Mamma Mia
here we go again as a man looking for
some late in life romance then in 2017
he published his Memoir entitled stay
interesting
child actor John Gilchrist appeared in
more than 200 commercials but the one
that made him truly famous was the
iconic spot for Life cereal that he
filmed in 1971. he was only three at the
time and he didn't even have any lines
but he still made quite the impression
he played a fussy eater named Mikey
whose enjoyment of a bowl of Life
surprises his brothers who were played
by gilchrist's real-life siblings he
likes it hey Mikey Gilchrist quit acting
in his late teens after losing the lead
role in the 1979 movie The Champ to
Ricky Schroeder he entered the
advertising business and ended up
working in radio at ESPN and eventually
for MSG networks which controls New
York's Madison Square Garden since 2006
he's held the position of director of
media sales
[Music]